- All right, y'all,
let's dip into the world
of social media before we say goodbye.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
A woman in southern California woke up
to her dog barking and
scratching at the floor.
She looked outside and noticed the cover
to her crawlspace ripped off.
When she went to investigate,
she discovered this.
(audience gasps)
It's a bear.
A several hundred pound black bear
just chilling under her
floorboards, hanging out.
Most of us would freak
out, but not this lady.
She managed to get the
bear out on her own.
How did she do it?
Let's find out for anyone else
who this happens to.
We have Tina on the line,
who watches on NBC Los Angeles.
What's up, Tina?
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello.
What did you do when you
found out it was a bear?
- I was so nervous when I saw
those eyes staring back at me.
You know, I live in a small suburb
of Los Angeles County called Monrovia,
and we get bears all the time.
So, I went back to bed
thinking no big deal.
But when my dog, Archie, went nuts,
I thought, "Is that bear
underneath my house?"
When I saw the crawlspace
grate ripped off its hinges,
I'm like, "Oh no, it's down there."
So, I walked down to my
basement with my flashlight
and the eyes shone right back at me.
I thought, "Oh no."
- What did you do?
- Well, I googled, "How to
get a bear out of crawlspace."
(audience laughing)
Nothing came up.
So, I thought, well, I'm gonna have
to take this in my own hands.
So, I turned my heater on real
high, made a bunch of noise.
I got some pots and pans
and started banging them.
It didn't budge.
I got my leaf blower.
I went down there and aimed it at him.
It didn't budge.
It was just laying there looking at me,
blinking at me with those cute eyes.
- Oh my god, God bless Google.
(Tina laughs)
How'd you finally get the bear out?
- Well, I reached out to our mayor
who had the police come by,
and they had a public safety
officer who knew about bears,
and he told me, "Get some moth balls
"and throw it up in your crawl space."
So I did, and it did the trick.
They don't like the smell of moth balls.
And that bear left.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Tina] I didn't want a bear sleepover.
- Yeah, that's a big black bear.
He is full.
Yeah, he's not skinny.
Well, thank you so much, Tina.
This is hilarious and I'm
liking your post right now.
I'm glad everything's okay.
(audience clapping)
(bell dings)
That picture, man, come
on, can't get over it.
Our season long partner, Pilot pen,
makers of Precise, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
love your story as much as we do,
so they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
So, maybe invest in some more moth balls.
(audience cheering)
All right, thank you, Tina, stay safe.
And thank you all our guests this hour,
Kathryn Newton, Cole
Sprouse, Zelda Williams,
Diablo Cody, Sarah J. Maas,
and the cast of "Kimberly Akimbo."
Y'all have a great day and
if it's not, change it.